bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end comme
tous les vendredis vous le savez nous
revenons sur les moments forts de
l'actualité culture loisirs et sports
au cours de cette émission nous vous
donnerons quelques idées de sorties en
ce début de vacances scolaires
ce sera avec sylvie là où la directrice
d'yveline tourisme
mais le démarrons tout d'abord avec un
artiste du xviiie siècle
pierre-antoine demachy son nom ne vous
dit peut être rien pourtant ces
peintures sont exposées dans les plus
grands musées français une exposition
lui est consacrée au musée lambinet à
versailles romain gravette
elodie moines se sont rendus sur place
ses peintures vous les avez peut-être
déjà vu le musée lambinet de versailles
accueille 50 des 300 oeuvres de pierre
antoine de machines emprunté au musée
carnavalet au louvre ou encore au
château de versailles
sept artistes du xviiie siècle reste
méconnu c'est la première fois qu'une
exposition monographique lui est
consacré c'est pas un mauvais peintre
simplement ce n'était pas un peintre qui
avait ses traits de génie qui ont
qui ont marqué les contemporains qui ont
fait qu'on parlait de levie en premier
partout en même temps à une époque où il
n'y avait pas la photographie et il y
avait à l'époque de la place pour des
peintres qui pratiquaient de leur métier
de manière tout à fait honnête qui avait
un bon métier mais qui n'étaient pas
forcément les célébrités de leur art les
oeuvres de pierre antoine demachy
témoignent de l'évolution urbaine de
paris au cours du xviiie siècle
il a représenté également des
architectures rêver issus des mines de
l'antiquité et de son imagination
l'exposition se déroule du 15 février au
18 mai je vous le disais dans les titres
de cette édition avec nous aujourd'hui
sylvie la luna bonjour civile à aulas
bonjour je rappelle vous êtes la
directrice divine tourisme
even donné quelques idées de sorties en
ce début de vacances scolaires
on démarre tout d'abord nos caves
versailles avec des cours d'anglais en
cuisinant c'est ça
donc c'est plutôt ludique il y à la fois
les enfants apprennent à parler
l'anglais donc c'est terry belton qui
est une américaine qui propose ces cours
de cuisine
donc effectivement on apprend à faire
des plats qui sont des plats américain
puisque l'est donc des muffins aux noix
de pécan des muffins à la framboise ou
plein de choses encore également le
chicken pote paille plein de deux plans
américains et famille sy sarr voilà et
les ateliers en famille peuvent être
pratiqués parce que les précédents dont
je vous ai parlé sont ceux qui sont
faits pour les enfants ce en famille
c'est plutôt les fameux cupcakes qui
sont très à la mode depuis ces dernières
années donc qui font appel à la
créativité puisque on va faire le
glaçage avec plein de couleurs des
petites des petites fleurs de toutes les
couleurs c'est super sympa à faire en
famille et voilà ça crée le lien dans la
famille
pour les amateurs de cirque aussi la
bergerie de rambouillet propose des
spectacles et des ateliers de découverte
voilà c'est la bergerie nationale à
rambouillet effectivement
qui propose de rentrer dans l'univers du
cirque donc l'univers du cirque
ça va des acrobaties au jonglage et puis
on a aussi des déguisements que l'on que
l'on peut faire on se déguise en clowns
ont fait des masques en forme d'animaux
et puis il ya le fermier magicien qui va
vous faire des tas de tours donc la
bergerie nationale se transforme
littéralement en syrie ont cassé quatre
euros par enfant 6 euros par adulte
c'est tout à fait ça elle encourt
ensuite les jeux sont à l'honneur à
france miniature france miniature
réouvre après une interruption donc pour
les vacances d'hiver
et comme ce sont les vacances de
carnaval il en profite pour mettre le
jeu à l'honneur donc ce sont des jeux de
société des jeux de cartes des jeux de
stratégie que les jeunes vont pouvoir
pratiquer et puis en même temps aussi on
va on va apprendre à faire des masques
parce que c'est l'époque qui convient
donc c'est le moment de retourner à
france miniature est de faire une belle
sortie en famille au niveau des musées
aussi donc là plusieurs activités qui
son programme alors il ya le musée
fournaise à chatou et le musée
d'archéologie nationale de saint germain
en laye le lieu propose des animations
effectivement pour pour ces vacances de
carnaval
alors le musée fournaise là on va y
découvrir la vie de ceux qui ont été
dans la maison la mère fournaise la
propriétaire de cette maison fournaise
puisque avant d'être musée c'était une
maison un restaurant est donc cette mère
vous fournaise va vous raconter des
histoires palpitantes avec renard run
renoir le renard erreur et donc très
palpitante au bord de l'eau et aussi des
histoires un petit peu plus poétique et
puis au musée d'archéologie nationale or
là c'est tout autre chose puisque on
remonte le temps on va apprendre à
travailler nargis
il a travaillé avec les mosaïques on va
découvrir la vie des petits cro magnon
des petits mérovingiens ou des prix
gallo-romain voile gallo romain donc on
découvre un peu un peu tout ça et on est
transporté dans le temps donc c'est à la
fois on apprend des choses et en plus on
se distrait un autre bon plan aussi pour
occuper donc les enfants pendant ces
vacances les ateliers de la ferme
pédagogique de la base de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
oui avec les animaux avec les animaux
encore une fois on est à la bergerie
nationale cette fois ci on est à la
ferme pédagogique de saint quentin et
donc on apprend à s'occuper d'eux donc
aussi bien les animaux de la basse cour
les coques les oies les poules et les
petits lapins mais aussi les plus grands
mammifères comme les cochons les chèvres
les boutons par les chalands et on sent
même traire les chèvres exactement donc
on s'occupe de les nourrir de nettoyer
leur enclos et puis il ya un atelier moi
qui m'amuse beaucoup ça s'appelle de la
mamelle à la gamelle lire et donc ça
c'est de la traque de la chaire jusqu'à
la dégustation du fromage qu'on a fait
grâce à son lait alors pour les enfants
à l'âme d'artiste plutôt des ateliers
sont proposés à saint-germain-en-laye au
musée maurice saint denis brice de nice
maurice denis par maurice bresse denis
alors maurice denis qui s c'est un
peintre nabi c'est un courant de
peinture est donc là on va découvrir des
ateliers créatifs pour les enfants donc
on va apprendre à faire de la de la
gravure sur bois
de la gravure sur tout autre support
et puis en même temps on va aussi
réaliser une espèce de jeu qui vous
permet de découvrir tous les types de
tableaux qui ont été peints par les les
nabis les nabis c'est qu'ils s'appellent
les peintres mystère et ça ça se fait en
famille également donc un bon moment on
se au nord on s'enrichit culturellement
sans en avoir l'air puisque on s'amuse
alors ce n'est pas tout chateau de
rambouillet les petits et les plus
grands pourront voyager à travers les
époques
voilà donc on a toutes atteint
d'ateliers qui se font également au
château de rambouillet et puis pour
finir on va découvrir le film qui sort
en ce moment enfin plutôt l'histoire du
film puisqu'on va découvrir la belle et
la bête qui vous sera contée donc on est
à la fois dans l'actualité
cinématographique et dans l'histoire ok
enfin pour pour terminer à versailles
les enfants sont invités à découvrir les
senteurs voilà et là c'est à la cour des
senteurs à versailles et c'est la maison
guerlain qui propose les ateliers qui
dure 2h30 donc ça occupe bien les
enfants et on devient le petit guerlain
c'est à dire qu'on va découvrir toutes
les senteurs on va enrichir ses qualités
olfactives et on va créer son propre
parfum
donc les matières premières n'auront
plus de secrets pour les enfants et donc
c'est un atelier qui est hyper
enrichissant pour les pour les jeunes et
que l'on peut pratiquer à la cour des
senteurs le 26 février si je ne m'abuse
voilà c'est une date à ces absences et
une seule date alors que toutes les
autres dates sont beaucoup plus large
puisque en général elles sont sur la
durée des vacances scolaires merci s'ils
veulent à sylvie léonard on retrouve
dans 15 jours pour d'autres bons plans
merci à bientôt
alors direction l'afrique maintenant il
y a quelques jours une journée entière
était consacrée à la culture de ce
continent aux clayes-sous-bois les
participants ont notamment pu s'initier
à la danse
un reportage d'olivier maniscalco et de
jonathan goodman
vingt-quatre heures au rythme de
l'afrique
à l'initiative de l'association donc
qu'est mousseau basé au pays sous bois
une journée d'animation était organisée
samedi à l'école henri pons stage de
percussions et de danse ateliers
créatifs ou dégustation de spécialités
africaines
plus de 150 personnes ont participé à
l'événement un événement dont les
bénéfices serviront au financement d'un
centre socioculturel aishihik au village
de la banlieue d'abidjan laon
provisionnent effectivement au fur et à
mesure pour pouvoir participer à ce
projet l'école la base c'est payant donc
il ya des enfants qui n'ont pas la
chance d'aller à l'école
toutes les personnes qui sont là donc
les percussionnistes danseurs à toutes
les personnes pour les activités
créatives des enfants en fait sont venus
bénévolement donc tout ça dans le but de
récolter un maximum d'argent
des fonds qui vont permettre d'apprendre
à lire et à écrire aux enfants des
quartiers défavorisés mais aussi à
développer leur culture notamment par la
pratique des danses traditionnelles des
danses que le public a eu l'occasion de
découvrir durant ces 24 heures africaine
tout ce qu on vient des faits là
savaient pas qu'ils viendront dès la
guinée du mali et du burkina
voilà mais tu peux les retrouve aussi au
nord de la côte d'ivoire joue en valeur
qui s'assoit funérailles baptême on va
là où c'est peut-être comme ça en
afrique en voilà ça fait sept ans et je
vais dire à toutes les cellules
reste franco algérienne qui s'inspire de
la réalité de son propre parcours
le comte de bouderbala qui s'est lancé
il ya quelques années dans le stand-up a
joué avec succès ses spectacles d'abord
aux états unis avant d'arriver en france
le week-end dernier aurélia 2 bis il a
rencontré quelques minutes avant qu'ils
le montent sur la scène du prisme à
elancourt on les écoute
là vous êtes en tournée est-ce que vous
adapter au fil de de l'actualité ou du
moment dé certains sketchs oui beaucoup
d'adaptations après un film de l'acte eu
sans nécessairement tomber dans le
voilà là la polémique du jour parce qu
on est beaucoup dans les polémiques ces
temps ci mais il ya un fil rouge qui est
un fil conducteur qui traitent de sujets
assez intemporel qui est un peu la trame
dont vous parlez français états unis
avec en toile de fond de
l'américanisation la tente ou agressive
de la france mais oui à chaque fois je
rajoute des petites choses alors les
romains quand ils peuvent pas aller
bosser d'envoi les roumaines roumaine
s'est d'autres techniques plus
l'instinct maternel
cb
son fils comme si c'était le sien je
connais pas son enfant malade
oh non c'est pas mon fils il je me sens
bien ça va nous faire une pause 9 ou
quoi qu'est ce qui t'arrive
non jamais
j'ai pas cher pour le ton papa des
papiers à remplir ses ventes mais s'est
fait fait moi pour vous aider dans leurs
mains vous êtes dans l'écriture aussi
bien le deuxième spectacle oui est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en parler ou un
spectacle aura pas grand chose à voir
avec le premier donc on va vraiment
changer de thème ça sera dans la
continuité mais avec d'autres thèmes sur
un petit peu de foi sujets sociétaux
après voilà mariage pour tous les
enfants la place des enfants dans la
société la télévision le petit etemad
d'abrutissement des masses via la télé
tout un programme très bien et se serait
pas quand ça sera dur je penserai
courant 2014 mars avril commencent à
rôder un petit peu mais vraiment bien
rodée je pense - rentrée 2014
d'ici quelques mois alors merci beaucoup
ça me vois à jouy en josas cinéastes
amateurs se sont donné rendez vous pour
la cinquième édition du festival
international du court métrage
elsa zylberstein originaire de la
commune et marraine de l'événement s'est
prêté au jeu des échanges avec le public
aurélia delhi 6 et mickaël jarry le
temps d'un week end le théâtre du vieux
marché à jouy en josas s'est transformée
en salle obscure pour accueillir le
festival international court métrage
festival qui depuis cinq ans présente
des films courts nommé aux césar et aux
oscars au programme cette année 38 films
en compétition un jury de professionnels
et différentes animations pour le public
en marge des projections ciné concert
ciné des bassines et compte notamment
ainsi que l'ain et rendez vous phare la
rencontre de cinéma avec des
professionnels donner la possibilité au
public vraiment de de pouvoir
pouvoir poser les questions qui ne ce
qui ne veut pas forcément poser des
choses qui voudraient savoir
et voilà donc on a des invités comme
elsa zylberstein julie de bona et rcj
royan donc ce sont les trois invités
d'aujourd'hui qui qui ont accepté à
l'invitation qu'on va accepter le jeu
entre guillemets de pouvoir échanger
avec le public c'est vive le cinéma
les gens aiment toujours vous rencontrez
savoir ce que vous faites sur l'émouvant
de rencontrer des gens et c'est spécial
c'est symbolique pour moi georges aux as
j'ai commencé à 12 13 1 faire de la
danse je faisais des gars là dedans son
mois de juin dans cette salle des fêtes
et jonas s'est passé toute ma vie ici à
georgia c'était important et touchants
et symbolique pour moi de revenir ici
aujourd'hui était magique
j'étais très heureuse de voir comme on
dit des acteurs en vrai et puis j'ai
étonné de leur simplicité et puis de la
qualité des échanges de chaleur qui
s'est dégagé plus de l'évolution du
débat aussi parce qu'au début c'était et
j'en étais un peu plus réservé et au
bout d'un moment tout le monde tout le
monde est entré dans le vif du sujet
dans le jeu entre guillemets et puis et
puis il y eu des échanges très agréable
franchement j'ai trouvé ça très bien à
quelques semaines de la cérémonie des
césar le festival l'ombre d'un court à
tout d'un grand
la proximité des membres du jury les
échanges avec le public en plus à
saint-cyr-l'ecole maintenant le garage
anciennes et loisirs est un atelier
atypique le lieu pour redonner vie aux
voitures des années 50 mythe du macadam
christian neyrolles le gérant forme
également les équipages participant au
4l trophy aux bases de la mécanique
anthony res jonathan widemann et yang
christian neyrolles délivre ses derniers
conseils à cet équipage du 4l trophy
à tout juste deux cent mille kilomètres
le véhicule de martin et benoît va
participer à son second raid
autant dire
qu'il faudra savoir réagir au moindre
problème mécanique au milieu du désert
un peu perdue sous le capot c2i vinoy
sont venus dans ce garage saint cyrien
pour apprendre le b à ba de la clé à
molette
on joue pas faire d'eux des mécaniciens
voilà je leur apprends simplement
simplement à anticiper les pannes et
intervenir sur certaines petites pannes
au niveau de l'allumage carburation et
des trains roulants voilà ceci dit
lorsqu'il a joint de culasse
une distribution qui lâchent ils ne sont
pas aptes à le faire en très peu
christian merlin ou vers cet atelier il
y a quatre ans et depuis il passe ses
journées sous les capots de ces vieilles
dames des années 50 pour leur donner une
seconde vie sur le macadam
contrairement aux véhicules modernes
avec une 4l une simca ou encore une 504
nul besoin d'ordinateur de bord un
retour aux racines de la mécanique qui
connaît un grand succès il ya de plus en
plus de demandes
ça s'est démocratisée de par le fait que
les véhicules des années 60 sont
beaucoup plus faciles à rouler
entretenir que les véhicules des années
40 30
donc il ya un mouvement qui s'est créé
depuis quelques années ce qui concerne
l'aide au fil de 403 les deux poules de
quatre elle ya un engouement particulier
pour ces véhicules
de leur côté martin et benoît espère
avoir toutes les clés pour ramener leur
4l du maroc sur ses quatre roues
vous les avez aperçu dans dans ce
reportage benoît perrin et martin
moutons ont maintenant pris le départ de
la 17e édition du 4l trophy
direction le maroc anthony rech les
avait rencontrés alors qu'il venait tout
juste de terminer la préparation de leur
véhicule voici un extrait de leur
entrevue
benoît martin bonjour à tous les deux
merci nous accueillir dans ce garage
dédié aux voitures anciennes c'est ici
que vous préparez votre véhicule pour la
17e édition du 4l trophy ce raid
humanitaire on le rappelle réservé aux
étudiants et long de 6000 km qui
traverse la france l'espagne et le maroc
tout d'abord première question comment
est née votre projet de participation à
ce raid
benoît c'est un projet qui est né il ya
à peu près un an
on est tous les deux dans la même école
non école de commerce
et voilà c'était un projet donc on
nourrissait depuis plusieurs années et
puis cette année s'est présentée
l'opportunité d'y participer pour tous
les deux donc voilà on a surtout que
l'année prochaine en fait on va avoir un
stage de fin d'études c'est là la fin
des courses ier cela ça approche du coup
là c'était vraiment la dernière
opportunité puisque comme vous l'avez
dit en introduction baron n'a besoin
d'être étudiant pour le rêve donc
c'était l'occasion que jamais il y avait
chez vous le besoin de vivre quelque
chose d'extraordinaire ensemble partir
loin des bases versaillaise évinoise
pour vivre quelque chose ensemble
oui c'est ça exactement fait le côté à
la fois sportif et puis le peul aventure
on se dit à la fois le 4l trophy c'est
connu mais en même temps pas vous faites
moi je connaissais rien spécialement no
comment ça se passe qu'est ce qu'on va
faire si 1000 km à 2 dans une petite
voiture
j'ai en fait c'est le voilà c'est génial
d'avoir cette opportunité donc d'où
notre présence aujourd'hui vous disiez
un raid s'est jamais parfait il ya
toujours des petits ennuis mécaniques
qui va faire le mécanicien au milieu du
désert ben on est deux on est une équipe
de 2 donc on va s'y mettre à deux mais
il n'y a pas de pilote copilote pour
l'instant c'est chacun son tour dans les
lobes copilote alors dans ce raid il ya
aussi évidemment l'aspect humanitaire
qui compte beaucoup dans le 4l trophy
expliquez-nous un petit peu justement
les enjeux avec combien de denrées par
exemple vous devez partir et qu'est-ce
que vous emmenez alors chaque équipage
par avec environ entre 30 et 50 kg de
fournitures scolaires à destination des
enfants les plus démunis du maroc
donc c'est une opération qui est menée
avec l'association enfants du désert
vous voilà donc au total cette année on
sera plus de 1300 équipage donc je vous
laisse calculer le nombre de kilos que
ça va faire à l'arrivée c'est un rendez
vous que vous attendez justement cette
rencontre peut-être y aura peut-être des
enfants marocains qui attendront
impatiemment toutes vos fournitures non
oui c'est ça en fait à la fois il faudra
faire attention parce que l'organisation
précise bien quand on traverse des
villages ils sont ils sont prévenus au
niveau de l'organisation mais
évidemment ça n'empêche pas de faire des
arrêts tout au long du trophy et puis
après à l'arrivée puisque l'essentiel du
matériel qu'on apporte ce fait au
village à l'arrivée ou là le gros du
matériel et déposer raid veut dire
compétition va quand même mon petit peu
en parlait il ya un objectif de
classement pour votre tout premier raid
à tous les deux ou pas où c'est vraiment
le plaisir et la découverte
alors on y va tout d'abord pour le
plaisir et pour la découverte pour
l'expérience que ça représente
ensuite au niveau du classement bon on a
quand même voilà on aimerait bien être
plutôt que d'en positionner alors votre
budget avoisine à peu près les 8000
euros j'ai regardé ça de près cela a été
un parcours du combattant pour le réunir
ce budget on sait que c'est c'est pas
facile économiquement ce moment ça a été
difficile effectivement en fait on a
avec benoît on a on a démarré en fait en
amont par les grands groupes les grands
entreprises en fait on a été on a vite
déchanté c'est assez difficile puisqu'en
fait en fait si c'est un trop petit
budget pour que ça puisse réellement
intéresser les grands groupes du coup
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est ensuite dirigé
vers des commerçants locaux ce qui en
fait est beaucoup plus sympa puisqu'on a
contact avec les gens on se voit
directement il ya un impact réel quand
quelqu'un donne 2 300 euros pour un
encart assez concret alors qu'une grande
entreprise au final va c'est de la pub
partout ailleurs donc ça c'était un
point très positif mais difficile ils
font donc parti des 1300 équipage avoir
pris le départ le jeudi 13 février
on leur souhaite évidemment bonne route
à eux on termine cette édition avec
votre agenda du week end
tour d'abord du sport et du handball
féminin avec le championnat de france de
nationale 2 ce samedi 15 février c'est
la 14e journée
montigny cinquième au classement reçoit
bar-le-duc classé 9e ce sera au complexe
pierre de coubertin coup d'envoi à 20h30
ce samedi toujours à 15 heures au musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
des artistes vous font découvrir les
valeurs qui se cache derrière le hip hop
et vous parlent de leur production un
échange proposé dans le cadre de
l'exposition sur les cultures urbaines
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité en direct dès 18h pour le
7-8 l'actu avec wilfrid ritchie
d'ici là je vous souhaite un excellent
week end sur tv fils